so if you're trying to figure out why  you're unhappy  start with what routines you continually  doing that are negative and stick around  because in there is a way to get some  more happiness back  it's right there and all we have to do  is make sure first we're aware of them  and then once we're aware of them we  decide we're going to break them  we're going to find a payoff that's  above  those payoffs and it's a very simple  thing to do i'm going to ask you to do  one thing and it's so easy  whatever your bad habit is  all i want you to do  is rehearse  overcoming that bad habit  rehearse it  because see  what we think is that one day we're just  gonna break our bad habits and it's  gonna be instantaneous and easy  the thing is we have to practice  overcoming a bad habit to be able to do  it in real life